[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Google Birmingham
is pleased to welcome
the genre bending G. Love,
who, along with his band
Special Sauce, forms a group
that coined the term hip-hop
blues.
Right?
G. LOVE: Mm-hmm.
SPEAKER: All right.
G. LOVE: Yes, sir.
SPEAKER: With their most
recent released album,
"Love Saves the Day," the band
returns to their rock and roll
roots.
We'll talk a lot about
kind of the new album.
I found it fascinating.
I listened to it on
the plane last night.
G. Love's incredible career
has spanned 20 years--
over 20 years
producing 11 albums
with classic songs
such as "Baby's Got
Sauce," "Rodeo Clowns" with
Jack Johnson, "Cold Beverage"--
I love the mug over there--
"50 Ways to Leave Your Lover."
See?
Cold beverage.
G. LOVE: This is hot.
SPEAKER: That's right.
And this is your--
so tonight will
be your fourth or fifth
concert of this tour?
G. LOVE: Oh, yeah.
Yeah, the fifth show.
SPEAKER: The fifth show.
G. LOVE: Sixth show--
SPEAKER: The sixth one.
G. LOVE: --of our
Freedom World Tour.
SPEAKER: Going back on
the road for three months.
And, yeah, it's great
for you to take some time
to come to Google Detroit to
talk to us and play for us.
G. LOVE: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Thanks.
Thanks a lot.
G. LOVE: Thanks for having me.
SPEAKER: Of course.
[APPLAUSE]
All right, so let's go back
20-plus years, 23 years, right?
Something like that.
Your sound is very
cool, kind of unique.
You are originally from Philly.
How did you start?
G. LOVE: Yeah.
I was born and raised
in Philadelphia.
My mother kind of
got me involved
in playing music at a young
age, just probably how
most parents do.
I was drumming along the
back of the family station
wagon, along with the
radio, and she said, oh,
that sounded pretty good.
Do you want to
play an instrument?
So I said, oh, yeah.
I want to play guitar.
And so soon after that,
I was eight years old.
I found myself in
folk guitar lessons,
learning kind of old
time Joan Baez type folk
songs or something.
And I was terrible at
it, and I hated it.
It hurt my fingers.
And my mother was already better
at playing guitar than me,
so that was--
it was a struggle for the
first five years or so.
And then when I was
about 13, kind of
figured out how to tune it,
and it started sounding OK.
And then when I was 15,
I wrote my first tune.
And I think that was kind of
the age that a lot of, you know,
kids kind of come
into themselves when
they're about 15.
My son's 15 now.
Yeah.
Once I wrote that
first song, that
was, to me, the real
springboard which would,
you know, lead on into a
career in music and, you know,
being here today.
SPEAKER: So 13-- things clicked.
15-- you wrote your first song.
You still remember it, right?
G. LOVE: Oh, yeah.
SPEAKER: Which one was it?
What was it about?
G. LOVE: Well, I
never did record it.
Although, I have recorded
and released a lot of the
tunes that I wrote actually
when I was in high school.
The first tune,
it's a good example
of kind of how I write songs.
You know, I always
feel like a song can
feel like one thing
on the surface,
but in reality there can be a
lot of different circumstances
that kind of lead to
this thing happening.
And a lot of times
also a song, I feel,
should be kind of a
knee-jerk reaction,
and therefore, it's kind of real
and poignant and true to life.
So anyway, the first song
was about two people.
You know, I had a
little girlfriend.
And I think-- yeah, I was
just really, like, you know,
I figured I was
pretty much in love.
I was 15.
You know?
So it was kind of
my love for her.
But then also I think
more importantly
it was about my best friend
who actually is my manager now.
He was going to leave school
and go to boarding school.
So you know, I was
kind of bummed out.
I was pretty sad he was
going to be leaving the state
and everything.
So I had these emotions of
being in love with this--
with my little girlfriend
and then my best friend
leaving home.
So I wrote this song
that seems like a love
song on the outside, but I
feel like the emotion in it
was kind of more written
towards your friend.
So actually I've
kind of continued
to write, like I
said, like that.
One song can have a lot
of different meanings,
especially to me on
the inside of it.
SPEAKER: And with this one,
kind of to take off of that,
your songs are
really interesting.
Your videos are
extremely interesting.
You've almost got
like-- you know,
there's like a different
story from the visual aspect
than the song itself, both
lyrically and musically.
As I was kind of
preparing for this--
and again, I took
a couple quotes,
because people are describing
your music in a very
interesting, weird way.
"Groove heavy,
Chicago blues infused,
brand of stripped
down rock and roll."
G. LOVE: [LAUGHS] That's
like I can't figure out
what the hell this shit is.
SPEAKER: Exactly.
[LAUGHTER]
Another one, "unique, sloppy,
and laid back, blues sound
that encompasses classic R&B."
G. LOVE: [LAUGHS]
SPEAKER: Right?
And like, we are in Detroit.
You know?
Clearly there's lots
of Motown influence
as well in some of those songs.
So how would you describe it?
G. LOVE: Well, yeah,
we've kind of always--
we called it hip-hop blues.
I think that's the kind of--
it's funny.
Because people will say,
hey-- you know, I'll
get in a cab-- oh, you play?
What kind of music do you play?
Oh, well, I play hip-hop blues.
Oh, I love that kind of music.
Oh, really?
Because we're the only
people that do it.
[LAUGHTER] And you don't
know who the hell I am.
But yeah, I mean,
it's kind of what
our music of G. Love and
Special Sauce is anyhow.
The kind of blueprint
for it was I kind of
learned a lot of
Delta blues, people
like Robert Johnson
and Bukka White,
Bob Dylan, too,
and John Hammond.
And then also I grew
up in the first--
I'm 44.
So I look around the room.
There's probably
some people my age,
and you know, probably
the first generation
of kids that kind of
grow up with hip-hop.
So like I said, I was learning
folk music and then later
blues music in my room, which
is kind of a solo endeavor.
But then when I'm out
with my homies, you know,
we're listening to hip-hop, and
we're running around the city.
And of course, in
1987 or whatever,
there was a couple
white rappers.
There was the Beastie Boys.
Right?
They were huge.
And there was 3rd Bass
and then Vanilla Ice,
but everybody would
rag on him, you know?
But yeah, the point is that
the Beastie Boys seemed kind
of a fluke, and indeed
hip-hop was very--
it's a black music.
It's a black art form
from predominately black
neighborhoods.
It's a true cultural music
of America, like the same way
that Delta blues is.
And I've always found there's
a lot of correlation there.
But the point of the story
is that you never thought--
I never thought I
would be a rapper.
And I don't know
whether I am now,
but hip-hop is a large part
of our music, and I do rap.
So those two influences
kind of collided for me
in a really natural kind of way.
Because you know, I
was never planning
on the two of them
colliding, but really my life
was these-- were these two polar
opposite things, like Peter,
Paul, and Mary and
the Beastie Boys.
You know?
And I never thought
about combining them,
but eventually they just did.
Because I became a street
musician, and one night
when I was out there playing--
and this was like a great
epiphany of my life.
I started playing
this blues riff,
and then I finished the song.
And then I started rapping
the lyrics for one of Eric B.
and Rakim songs called "Paid
in Full" over top of it.
And then at that
moment, it was like,
you know, it was like
the clouds parted,
and it was like shining a light
on the street in Philadelphia.
And I was the only
kid in the world
at that moment playing a Dobro
acoustic guitar and rapping.
And I was like, OK,
well, now I got it.
And that was what you want
to have as a musician.
You want to find an
original take on something.
And then I had to explain it--
and that's the thing is that no
one knows what it--
no one could really
ever put us in a box.
It wasn't rock and roll.
It wasn't hip-hop.
So the record labels,
especially marketing people,
they want to have an
easy way to put you.
But they never could
figure out what to call us
or what section to put us.
You could go into
one Tower Records,
and we might be in
hip-hop, and then
another one would
be alternative rock.
So that's why we have
a lot of adjectives
and trying to figure out,
like, what we're doing.
SPEAKER: And then even with--
early on you got a decent
rotation at MTV network
when people were watching it and
when it actually played music.
Were you considered back
then with MTV hip-hop?
Because, again, your videos,
especially the older ones,
I watched them on YouTube, and
they're very black and white,
very soul and blues
kind of videos.
So I'm very curious about going
from the 15-year-old who wrote
the song, to being
a street musician,
to finding your sound, then
getting on MTV, figuring out--
when did you have
to stop explaining
and actually start
playing and touring?
G. LOVE: Never.
[LAUGHTER] No.
I mean, it's kind of
an interesting thing
to talk about,
because, you know,
when we first came out with
the first record, everything
changes in your life, right?
You go from being a
street performer, which
everybody in my band,
which is a trio,
started as a street performer
in Boston or Philadelphia.
And so you think about,
like, you're really
living on the fringe
of society, right?
So you're kind of very far
away from corporate America.
You're very far away
from making any money.
You're 100 light years away
from the record labels,
which are really just a
couple hours down the road
in New York City.
You're a million miles away
from MTV and all the real music
that you see every day on that.
And holy shit-- then all of
a sudden you send your demo,
and then you have the
opportunity to play.
And then they liked
it, and then now you're
getting a record deal.
And all of a sudden you
went from not having a job,
except for playing as
a street performer,
to now working for Sony Music
and having a pocketful of money
but working for one of
the biggest corporations,
not only in America,
but in the world, right?
So, like, for us it
was like overnight life
changed completely.
And along with that, then
all of a sudden people
want to know, well,
why are you here?
What gives you the
right to be here?
Right?
What's this music that
you're playing all about?
I don't know what this is.
Explain it to us.
And then, of course,
for us, being
like a white kid from
Philadelphia in the 80s, like,
what gives you the right
to play blues music?
And what gives you the
right to play hip-hop?
Because clearly you're
not built for that.
And that was like a really big
thing in my early 20s was--
whether you're, like,
defending your right
to play this type of
music or explaining
why you came about doing
it in the first place.
It was never
comfortable, you know?
And especially when you go over
to Europe or you go to Japan,
then they really
hone in on this.
And so that was an interesting
thing to kind of juggle,
you know, mentally
and emotionally.
What gives you the right
to play this music?
And then, of course,
you meet the artist--
because we've toured
with everybody
from Buddy Guy, who signed
my guitar here, to Run DMC,
and everybody you can
imagine, you know, A Tribe
Called Quest, and Gang Starr.
SPEAKER: Dave Matthews Band.
G. LOVE: Dave Matthews Band.
But I was really talking
about like the hip-hop people,
because these people, these
artists, they would never say,
like, you know, why
are you doing this?
Well, of course,
they knew right away.
They could tell, you know,
whatever we're doing,
this is what they do.
Right?
You do it because
you have to do it.
And so the artists were
always very supportive,
which was nice.
You know, Q-Tip would never
say, yo, G., you're white.
Why are you rapping?
He was like, yeah,
man, I'm a fan.
You know?
And I was like, oh, my god.
So yeah.
SPEAKER: So your early 20s--
G. LOVE: I don't know if I
answered any of your questions
or anything.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: I don't know
about the questions,
but the answers are great.
This is good.
So you know, early 20s,
you make it a little bit.
You get on MTV.
You tour a lot.
Then you guys decide to,
or choose to, or end up
taking a fairly long break.
And then right now-- because
you mentioned it, right?
Right now you're in your 40s.
You're back with a new
album, back on the road.
I'm just kind of
curious mentally-- how
are you approaching your
touring times right now
versus what you were
doing in the past?
G. LOVE: Oh, I like to think
that we finally figured out
this whole thing now.
You know what I mean?
Because there's
definitely-- god.
The music business has changed,
and it's always changing.
You know?
Certainly because
technology and you
know things that you guys
are involved in for sure.
And you know, basically I
got signed when I was 20,
so I really didn't know
anything about anything other
than playing music.
And it was a big learning curve.
I definitely made a lot
of mistakes along the way,
trying to figure out how to
navigate through the music
business.
And like I said,
that's always changing.
So how do I approach
touring now differently?
You know, we have a saying
that's called back in the van
again.
Right?
Because you spend a lot of
time when you're coming up
riding around in a van.
And you know the 12-passenger
vans that you rent from Budget,
like the Ford 150, 12
passenger, white van.
You don't want to get
back in the van again.
Right?
So that's how you
approach a tour.
We're not-- we're
going to do whatever
we have to do to not
be back in the van.
Right?
Meaning, we want-- we've got a
tour bus, so traveling in a van
is pretty tough.
It's great if you're like
22 years old and don't--
that's cool.
But when you're like
in your 40s, which--
well, actually,
I'm the only person
in my band left in their 40s.
My drummer and bass player
are now in their 50s.
So we approach touring
like a small business.
So that's kind of what
we've always been.
Once we figured out, OK,
aside from the music,
this is a small business.
Because we've never
really had like--
even though we got signed
and had that success which
seemed overnight,
really all that did
was basically like you've got
a record deal that basically
is like a small business loan.
Right?
And then that set us on the
way to keeping our business up,
and our store is what we set up
on stage every night to sell,
like a pop-up shop.
You know?
So I think we approach
our touring like that,
like on the business side.
That's how we run it.
It's pretty grassroots.
You know, we have
a small business.
There's two people in the
front office in New York,
and there's six of us on the
road, including band and crew.
And then we have, you know,
an accountant and lawyer,
and they're kind of independent.
But yeah, you got to look at
the road as being a marathon
not a sprint.
And one thing that I--
one thing that I have kind
of realized along the way
is that you're basically
rowing around in circles.
So the world is so big you
can't get to every place you
want to get to every year.
So it's best to take your time.
It's a marathon.
SPEAKER: Well, and one thing
I didn't know about you,
which I thought was
really interesting,
the children's book
that you wrote.
So you know, "Little Daddies--
A Book for Kids with
Traveling Dads."
Clearly being for so long away
from home and having-- you
said your kid right now is 15?
G. LOVE: Yeah.
SPEAKER: So, I
mean, I have kids.
Many of us have
both families and we
travel for different reasons.
It's very different.
But I would love to
just kind of hear
from you what got you
to write this song.
What was the experience?
And did it impact you and
your son and the relationship
that you have had that
you have right now?
G. LOVE: Yeah, you
know, actually I
have a 15-year-old boy, and
I have a 10-month-old boy.
So, you know, whoops.
[LAUGHTER]
But fatherhood has been
the best thing for my life.
You never think it's going
to happen, but then it does.
It's like the
greatest thing ever.
So I'm not really great
at planning things.
But you know,
certainly being a dad
has been the greatest
gift of my life.
And so one thing is that
if you guys travel a lot,
like everybody
travels these days,
so it never gets comfortable or
easy to leave your kid at home,
really no matter
how old they are.
Like I said, my
older son is 15 now,
and he's a full-on teenager.
And every time I drop him
off, I'm like, (WEAKLY) bye,
I got to go.
See you in a couple weeks.
You know?
It never gets easy
to say goodbye.
And I think it's almost
easier for the kids
than it is for the parents,
because you feel, like,
so much guilt. And oh,
my god, I'm leaving.
So anyhow, when my
older son was a toddler,
I would say, OK, where's
daddy going to be?
And then he would
point to his heart.
And then I'd say, OK,
where's Aiden going to be?
And he'd point at my heart.
And we'd say we always keep each
other in each other's hearts.
And that was the
premise of this book,
this book called
"Little Daddies--
A Book for Kids with
Traveling Dads."
It's on Amazon.
They print it up there.
You can Google it and find it.
And then hopefully
it'll sell enough copies
so that I can write
"Little Mommies," you know,
the book for kids
with traveling moms.
You know, one thing at a time.
But, you know, that's been good.
My older son, actually, his
step-dad is a musician as well.
So I couldn't quite
figure out why
his mother went with
him because she was so
aggravated with what I did.
She, of course, went
with another musician.
But we're great
friends, all of us.
And you know, I don't know.
It is a juggle, though,
traveling so much.
Because I probably do
travel like 250 days a year.
I don't do 250
shows, but I think
that's about how much
we're away from home.
I figured out-- I think it's
like every time I spend a night
at home, it costs
me like $1,000--
it's like $1,000 hotel room.
You know, that's how many--
like if I'm home for--
if my mortgage is $4,000,
I'm home four nights a month.
You know what I mean?
It's like, damn, this
is an expensive hotel.
This place is so expensive.
[LAUGHS] But yeah, you
know, it is something.
It's tough to be away.
Like they say, you
never get the time back.
And that's something that I
think now that my son is 15,
he's a sophomore, I can see him
already walking out the door.
And I'm just like, oh, you
know, I have a lot of emotions.
Like, man, you know, you
never get that time back.
I don't know what to
say other than that.
That part of it is a
tough part of the job.
SPEAKER: I have a
couple more questions.
I want to make sure that
we leave time for you
guys for Q&A. All right,
before we go into the "Love
Saves the Day," you did
a couple of commercials--
Coke, Cadillac.
You are on YouTube right
now, having actually like
1.2, 1.3 million views for
some of your kind of older
songs, good stuff.
I know many of the artists,
many of the musicians,
they look at social media.
They look at some
of those things--
Spotify, YouTube, being in
commercials as being something
they hate doing or
they have to do,
versus others just embrace it.
Now, the whole idea of you as
a musician making money off
of album sales I think is kind
of gone back into history.
So I'm curious from you--
I love the analogy of small
business, a pop-up shop.
How are you thinking
of digital--
YouTube, Spotify, social media?
What does it mean for you
as being a musician that's
on the road 250 days a year?
G. LOVE: Well, I think
now, like in the past year
or whatever, just
very recently, they're
finally starting
to figure it out,
and there's a lot
more transparency
in the digital music thing.
So you know, that's one
thing about my career.
I've really seen--
I got signed kind of five
years before the very peak
of the industry.
So if you look at it like--
I think it was like
1999 or something
when N'Sync put
out a huge record,
and it was like the
most records sold ever.
You know?
Like way more than
the Beatles ever sold
in like a day or something.
If you look at that as like the
peak of the commercialization
of the success of the
music industry, then
after that Napster came
along, then there was 9/11.
And it all hit at the same time.
And just to put it
in perspective, like,
in October of 2001, like
less than a month after 9/11,
we got a call from our A&R guy.
And you know, I just
happened to be in the office,
and I said, oh, hey, Mike.
How Are you calling to drop us?
And he goes-- and I was just
joking, but I kind of knew it.
And he was like, actually, yeah.
I'm calling to-- you know, it's
been a great run, you know?
Love ya.
That was last time I
ever talked to him.
And so between 9/11 and
Napster, the music industry
really shit the bed.
And then for the last almost
20 years between that, now
it's been kind of trying
to figure itself out.
And now with Spotify and
different streaming services,
like I said, there's
more transparency.
And now the artists
and the labels
are starting to get
paid from the streaming.
And because the consumer
likes the streaming,
now you don't hear about people
like pirating or stealing
music, right?
Because everyone
gets it for free now
or with a small
subscription fee, and that
works out for everybody.
So now you have a chance to make
money off it, which is good.
Because if the record
labels can make money,
then they can give
budgets to people like us
to make music because
it does cost--
it does cost a certain
amount of money
to make a high quality record.
You have to pay musicians.
You have to pay for studio
time and everything else.
So I see now--
now we see, like, good things
starting to happen again.
And so I feel better
about the music business.
SPEAKER: Was it-- the Cadillac.
Cadillac actually had
a pretty heavy rotation
of the commercial.
G. LOVE: Oh, yeah.
SPEAKER: They used
some of your song.
Was it pretty cool?
Did people text you just like,
hey, I just heard your song
in the commercial?
G. LOVE: Yeah.
Actually, so back
to the commercials--
the whole thing
about commercials
was that commercials--
and if you're a musician,
if you had a chance
to do a commercial,
it was really a sellout move.
That was the way our
generation perceived it.
Right?
And to me, that ended when there
was two major commercials--
I don't know if you
remember-- but when
the Beatles' "Revolution"
was in a Nike commercial.
And then I think there was
a Led Zeppelin song that
was used in a commercial.
And then Bob Dylan was
physically in a Victoria's
Secret commercial.
Do you guys remember
that at all?
It was like the weirdest
like-- it was like a Victoria's
Secret commercial,
and all of a sudden
there was Bob Dylan
just sitting there.
And you're like, what
the-- what is this?
You're like, OK, man, well,
now it's all open season.
And yeah, I'd
certainly like to--
if you're me, you pray to God
that sometime during the year
you're going to get that
call where, oh, Google
wants to use this song, an
old song, or a new song,
or they want you to write
a song, or whatever.
It's, yes, we want to do it.
Because for us, it's like
money that you don't expect,
and on top of that,
more importantly,
in this day and age I
feel like it's so hard
to make a splash anywhere.
There's so many outlets where
people are getting everything
from you can't have--
you can't achieve
maximum exposure.
So every time you get a
song played on anything
it's like a win.
So us now, it's like--
whereas before it would be
a real emotional struggle.
Oh, my god, well,
Coca-Cola wants
to give us more money than
we've ever made on anything,
but now, look, we could
lose all our fanbase.
This is a real problem.
We could take this money from
Coca-Cola or Philip Morris.
But, god, if we do
this, we're going
to upset our fans and
the rock and roll gods.
I remember, I really did have--
and we passed a lot of stuff.
We left a lot of money on
the table for this reason.
We left a huge Miller Light
commercial on the table.
It was definitely like
a three figure deal,
and it was probably like,
well, no, that's a sellout.
We can't do that.
Or TGIF Friday's wants to
use your song "Baby's Got
Sauce" in a rib
commercial in the UK only.
No, can't do that.
Philip Morris wants to use
your song "Cold Beverage"
in Eastern Europe only.
And I said, well, tell
them they can use it
if they give me $1 million.
Well, they never
replied, you know?
I was just basically
saying, you know, fuck you.
I'm not doing that.
You know what I mean?
And now you think
back, you're like,
damn, I should've taken that.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: So "Loves Saves
the Day," your newest album.
First of all, where
do you record?
In Philly or do you go
somewhere else to record it?
G. LOVE: We recorded the
latest record and actually
our last couple records
in Brushfire Studios,
which is Jack Johnson's record
label and studio in Hollywood.
SPEAKER: OK.
Cool.
So how is this one different
from some of the other work?
G. LOVE: Well, I mean, this
record for us was kind of--
records kind of flow, and
the music is always flowing,
and one thing leads to another.
So our previous record
was called "Sugar,"
and I felt like we kind of
stumbled upon the modern day
version of the
hip-hop blues, which
was very clear cut this time.
It was like Cypress
Hill style beats
with Elmore James style guitar.
Right?
So it was like, OK,
and that was the song
actually they used in that
Cadillac commercial called
"Come Up Man."
Anyways, I felt like, OK,
now we got a really concrete
blueprint, and we're going to
really push it on this record.
So we really pushed
that sound, and then it
ended up being rock and roll.
Because basically if you
push the blues enough,
it ends up being
rock and roll, right?
That's how rock and
roll was invented.
So we finally, after 25
years, figured out how
to play rock and roll.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: All right,
let's transition to some
of the questions, Q&As.
So again, raise your
hand and wait for a mic.
G. LOVE: Someone
please have a question.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Laura-- long,
long, long time fan.
G. LOVE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for being here.
We were talking
earlier actually today
about a couple of our
favorite live performers
and how it is so different to
see them in different cities
and at different
venues, and how they
can kind of vibe off of the
city or even the venue itself.
So outside of your
roots in Philly--
because it wouldn't be
fair to include that--
do you have a favorite venue or
a favorite city to perform in?
And you don't have to
say Detroit, either.
G. LOVE: Detroit!
The MGM Grand tonight.
[LAUGHTER]
No, that's a good question.
I mean, really,
short answer is no,
because I really do like to--
every night you're in a
chance-- and like you said,
you have a room full of people.
It's a different room,
different crowd. .
You have a chance to vibe with
them and connect with them
and make something happen,
like, with your guitar
and a microphone.
And to me, a great
experience can
happen at like a really
prestigious club,
like The Fillmore
in San Francisco,
or it can happen at the
corner bar, you know?
And it often does.
And honestly, sometimes a lot
of the bigger famous rooms,
like Red Rocks, for instance.
You know, if you were
going to say like--
if you were going to say,
what are the best venues?
Well, then you have to say
like Red Rocks, or The Gorge
in Washington, which is on the
banks of the Columbia River
Canyon.
The sun goes down, and then the
moon rises behind the stage,
and it's really a beautiful
place to see or play.
But like Red Rocks
is one of these rooms
where I feel like every time--
I've had the opportunity
to headline it twice.
And I feel like it's really
kicked my ass every time.
It's like, you know,
you're backstage,
and you're walking around.
You're looking at all
the pictures of people
who played there like.
You grew up-- like there's
the Beatles played there,
and you know that U2 did
the "Sunday Bloody Sunday"
video there.
And you're like, now
I got to go out there.
AUDIENCE: I saw
you at Red Rocks.
G. LOVE: Oh, you did?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
G. LOVE: Well, hopefully you
had a better time than I did.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I did, definitely.
G. LOVE: Oh, good.
Yeah.
So, yeah, it can
happen anywhere.
But I just like to--
I like the experience, you know?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming in today.
Like Laura, I'm a long time fan.
I think the first time I saw you
was 10 years ago with Donavon
Frankenreiter and Jack Johnson.
So you've described
yourself as hip hop blues.
So how did you meet up with
Jack Johnson and "Brushfire
Fairytales"?
That's very not
hip hop in a sense.
It's a good blend of the two.
So how did you meet
up with those guys?
G. LOVE: Well, that's
a good story, too.
Jack was-- OK, a buddy of
mine from Avalon, New Jersey--
because I grew up in
Philadelphia in the city,
but then in the summer
time me and my family
would stay in at
the Jersey Shore.
So I grew up surfing,
and so I had a lot of--
you know, we had a little
surf town in New Jersey.
One of these guys that
I was growing up with,
he ended up being
a surf photographer
and met up with Jack Johnson
and the Malloy brothers.
And they were making
these surf films,
and they were stealing my music.
So they had put about
seven of our tunes
in a couple of their movies
and not cleared it, you know?
So a surfing buddy
was, like, hey, man--
yo, G., man.
This kid I looked up to
my whole life, you know,
because I was never
very good at surfing.
So the cool kid was like,
yo, Garrett, come over.
You've got to come over
to my house right now.
Oh, my god.
And then he was like, look,
your music's in this movie.
I was like, damn,
they stole that shit.
[LAUGHTER]
So then we got in
touch with them.
So the first interaction with
Jack and his surfing buddies
was like, yo, you
stole our music.
And then they said, OK, well,
here's some surf wax and surf
leashes and track top.
Like, OK, thanks.
But then I did have the
opportunity to meet Jack.
So he was just a kid,
and he had a guitar,
and we went for a surf.
And then we traded songs, and he
kept singing all of his tunes.
One part of me was like,
this guy's a cool kid.
And one part of me was like,
this guy's a fucking rockstar.
And the songs were like--
he basically played me
that whole first record,
"Brushfire
Fairytales," and yeah.
So I think long
story short, he was
a big fan from when he grew up.
It's been great, because
our music has really
rubbed off on one another.
And actually, if you do
listen to Jack's flow,
he actually really
is like a rapper.
He's actually-- even
though he's not a rapper,
he's floating as if--
and he's a real lyricist.
Yeah, it's been a
great relationship.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming in.
Any favorite memories
or funny stories
from traveling or being on
the road all those years?
G. LOVE: Yeah, a couple.
I'm trying to think if there
was a good one in Detroit.
I don't know.
Do you want to
hear a dirty story?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Yes.
G. LOVE: I don't know.
Well, I don't know.
There is one funny--
I don't want to
tell a dirty story.
I always do this.
AUDIENCE: Tell us after.
G. LOVE: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Tell us
the dirty one after.
G. LOVE: OK, after.
That's like a tough
question, tell a funny story
from the road.
I don't know.
Let me come back
to that, because I
got to think of one that's
not too dirty and appropriate
for the internet.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Well, as
you think of it,
we probably have time for
one, maybe two more questions,
before we do the performance.
So again, raise your hand.
AUDIENCE: How's it going?
G. LOVE: Good.
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned you obviously
are very influenced
by the blues,
and you specifically called
out Buddy Guy as somebody
that you'd open for before.
I was wondering if there was
like ever a group you were
opening for that you were
a big fan of or like kind
of starstruck going in
and talking with them
and kind of how that played out.
G. LOVE: Yeah.
That's a lot of people.
Well, actually,
here's a funny story,
and it will go with
the last one, too.
But this is kind of a funny one,
because it kind of encompasses
both things.
Back in the day there was this
festival, The H.O.R.D.E Tour,
right?
And this is cool because
Blues Traveler, who actually I
toured with last summer,
this was their thing,
and they were running it.
And this was amazing,
because three years
before I had jumped over
the fence when I was 16
and snuck into the Blues
Traveler opening up
for the Allman Brothers
show in Philadelphia.
And I was like, you know,
backstage at catering,
and there's John Popper
and all these people
and all these musicians.
And this one guy comes
up to me and goes,
hey, man, are you G. Love?
And I was kind of
pretty shy when I was--
well, not shy, but when I
was 20 I was a different guy.
I was kind of keeping to myself.
Hey, are you G. Love?
Oh, yeah, I am.
How are you doing?
Oh, man, I really love your
record, really big fan.
Oh, thank you so much.
And I'm like, you know,
so what do you do?
Oh, are you a musician?
Oh, yeah, I'm a musician.
Well, what's your name?
I'm Dave.
Nice to meet you.
Well, what's your-- what's
the name of your band?
Oh, Dave Matthews Band.
[LAUGHTER]
I was like all right, man.
Well, great to meet you, man.
Good luck.
Good luck out there.
[LAUGHTER]
I had no idea who he was.
He was like, yeah,
I'm Dave Matthews.
What's your band?
Oh, Dave Matthews Band.
And so now like--
and then, of course, Dave
Matthews from that summer,
which was '95, that
was probably when
he was just starting to break.
But, like, I was just
listening to the blues.
I had no idea who this guy was.
It took me years to understand
kind of what they do,
and why it's successful, and why
people love it, and I love it.
But now I have a running
thing of like stupid things
that I say to Dave Matthews.
Because every time I see Dave--
he's like the nicest guy.
But every time I'd say
the stupidest shit to him
every time.
Because whenever you open for
him, he'll come backstage.
He's one of the few
guys, when you're
opening for him,
whoever's opening for him,
he meets you backstage,
and then he introduces
you to like the five people
that aren't in the parking lot,
and they're actually going
to watch you play out
of the 50,000 that
are going to be there.
I think the last time I
said to Dave, I was like--
it was at The Gorge.
And they had this bluegrass
guy sitting in with them.
And he sang this
great song called,
"By the Side of the Road."
And I was like, oh, this
is the greatest song ever,
"By the Side of the Road."
So then the second
day, Dave's there,
and his voice was hurting.
And I go, Dave, man,
great show last night.
I got a new favorite song.
And he's like, oh, which one?
I was like, "By the
Side of the Road."
It's not even his song.
It's the other guy's song.
I'm like, fuck.
[LAUGHTER]
Anyway, yeah, but long story
short, yeah, I get starstruck.
I get starstruck a lot.
That's probably like why--
I'm like a fan
first, which is why
I get people to sign my guitar.
The most recent funny one
was we toured with Cypress
Hill two summers ago.
And my guitar tech is
named Big Scrimp, right?
And he's this big,
fat, bald guy,
and he looks real
mean and tough.
But you know, he's one of these
guys who's like a teddy bear
once you know him.
But him and I are really
big fans of Cypress Hill.
So we're like two little
schoolgirls in catering,
we're like, there's B-Real.
There's Sen Dog.
I'm like, hey, hey,
B. We used to have
all these jokes, like, yeah,
we get totally starstruck.
It's pretty funny.
SPEAKER: So you guys are
ready for some music?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SPEAKER: All right.
G. LOVE: Oh, man.
This song is about I-95 and
everything that happens on it.
One time I was driving from New
York City back up to Boston,
and I wrote it down.
And it goes like this.
(SINGING) I'm going
back to Boston.
I think I'm losing my mind.
I'm going back to
Boston, driving I-95.
Well, I know your girl, she
ain't no friend of mine.
Boston called me, and see them
women wearin' too much clothes.
Yeah, them Boston girls, they
don't like to stay at home.
Oh, when that sun
is shining, they
got a lot of leg that shows.
Show it, baby.
Whoa, I'm a good man, so
I need a good woman, too.
I'm a real good man.
Oh, I need a good woman, too.
Well, that girl I love don't do
nothin' but give me the blues.
Blues.
Whoa, we was to be married,
married in the spring.
Whoa, married.
I'd give her my diamond ring.
Whoa, now she changed her mind.
She doing' her own thing.
Now do your thing,
baby, like this now.
I like it when you
do your thing now.
I just wish you'd do your thing
with me one of these old times.
Come on back home, baby.
I'll treat you right.
Now let's go get her, fella.
Boston winters, they
so long and rough.
And all these Boston girls,
they got to stay all covered up.
But when it's summer time
they sure lookin' good enough.
Oh!
But not as good as those
girls from Detroit.
What?
Whoa!
I'm looking for a woman that's
looking for a worry man.
Oh, now, I'm lookin' for a woman
that's lookin' for a worry man.
Oh, that New York
girl, she don't never
try to understand me, though.
So I'm going back to Boston.
I think I'm losing my mind.
Yeah, back to
Boston, driving I-95.
I've got to find a good
lookin' woman, oh, she
gonna' help me ease my mind.
Ease me, baby.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
You got it.
[LAUGHS] This next song is
called "Bad Girl Baby Blues."
[STRUMMING GUITAR]
There's spin some old
time record, baby.
Or just give me
half a chance to get
you dancin' round my room with
nothin' but your underpants.
Light some candles.
Oh, we gonna burn
one down tonight.
We've been blacked out
bruised, bloodshot and blue.
Torn down from the strung
out misused and confused.
We had our bouts and our doubts.
Oh, I'm still crazy over you.
It's hard to say all the reasons
that I love you, baby, when
you're pushin' me out the door.
Don't you do it, baby.
I once had a heart.
Oh, I gave it away.
Now it's yours, honey.
So treat it good.
Let's get some pawn shop glasses
with a little Pinot noir.
Oh, just look at
me deeply, baby.
I'm the man that knows
just who you are.
You're the one I choose.
I refuse to lose my
bad girl baby blues.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
I had to play this song today
because it's Inauguration Day.
I look forward to writing
a lot of great songs
in the next four years.
[LAUGHTER]
It's been real
hard on us artists
to write the last eight.
[CHUCKLES] [INAUDIBLE]
[STRUMMING GUITAR]
(SINGING) Yeah, but
once in a while,
I've got to use my superpowers.
Even or saving or
what that'll stop.
It ain't my fault all this
bad stuff is happening.
Oh, now it's time I
put my foot on down.
Oh, baby, my love
don't seem the same.
Oh, no it don't.
Man, they say that love is all
you need to heal the world,
pus a trillion billion dollars.
Have you heard that President
Trump, Santa Claus, and Green
Goblin, Saddam Hussein,
Spiderman, and Bin Laden,
Britney Spears, Jesus, and
the cast of the "Friends"
met for brunch last week to
solve the world's problems?
Would've called on me.
Oh, baby, my love
don't seem the same.
Man, if they called on my
name, don't you know I'd do it?
Shine my signal over
Detroit, I'd be true.
It is my distinct pleasure
to come down from my grass,
get off of my front porch
and save all your asses.
And in the nick of time, too.
Oh, baby, my love
don't seem the same.
Aw, man, change has come
over me, my muscle growin'.
So I freestyled my
ass across the USA.
Solved the economy,
changed the environment,
save the environment,
change what you're doin'.
Yeah, man.
Aw, baby.
Man, if you can't do smack,
but you better do something.
This is the time when
you so can't do nothing.
That means you, and
you, and you, and you,
and you, and you, and me, too.
Oh, baby.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, man.
Uh-huh.
Well, then I fly overseas
and set all the slaves
free from prostitution,
sweat shops, child labor,
solved a myriad a bombs
in the Middle East.
Make a sun power pony.
We have to fight for oil fields.
Then I'll take all the troops
back from wherever they roam,
and whatever they're fightin',
and whatever side they're on.
Send them on the first
plane home to their moms,
so we can make coffee tables
out of all these bombs.
And save the whales and
the pygmy marmosets, too.
Oh, baby.
Yeah!
Man, all this
seems kind of hard,
but it really ain't nothin'.
All you got to do is get
by a spider or something.
We could change the
world in a week or a day.
And if you got problems,
well, I'll sweep them away.
So if you find yourself in
a world full of trouble,
just call on G. Love,
the superhero brother.
And I'll be there.
Yeah, I'll be there.
Oh, I'll be there.
You know I'll be there.
Oh, baby.
My love don't seem the same.
No, no, no, no.
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE] It's good to
hear a brother mess up
a couple lyrics.
All right, well,
I'll do one more.
AUDIENCE: Yeah!
G. LOVE: Special requests?
To the lovely ladies
in the front here.
Thank you, guys, so much
for having me out today.
And--
[STRUMS AND PLAYS HARMONICA]
And we'll be at the
MGM Grand tonight
if you want to come get
lucky at the casino.
Although, I did realize--
it's a tough pill to swallow.
But the easiest way
I can make money
is playing the guitar,
because I'm a lousy gambler.
[LAUGHTER]
As I found out, again.
Now we're starting
to play more casinos,
so it's always tough not
to take your gig money
and go put it on black.
[LAUGHTER]
All right, now this
song, "Baby's Got Sauce,"
so this was one of my
original tunes, right?
And this was-- the
version I'm going
to play for you is the
original version before I met
my band and my drummer, put the
words on a different groove,
and that became the
song that you guys know.
But this is the original
version, all right?
So you can't be like, oh,
man, G. fucked the song,
man, he changed it up.
This is how it goes.
This is originally how it goes.
OK?
So it goes like this, all right?
[TUNES HARMONICA]
It's the same thing.
It just goes a lot faster,
you know what I mean?
If you don't like it, that's
good, it'll be going quicker.
[LAUGHTER]
(SINGING) Cooling out, cooling
out, waiting for my lady.
Got the special sauce.
She is my baby,
my baby, my baby.
And of course, I'll do anything
for her, anything she wants.
Sure, honey, got a sharp
mouth, a sharp tongue.
Gimme gimme some.
Don't take to that,
gimme gimme none.
You got to work and deserve
it, earn it to own it.
Then once you got, never
ever gonna leave it alone,
don't take wise crackin' or
forgetting never been stood up.
Yo, she does the stepping.
You know my baby got sauce.
Your baby ain't sweet like mine.
Whoa!
She ain't sweet like mine.
She got sauce.
Your ain't baby ain't
sweet like mine.
She got sauce.
Whoa!
Yeah, she got sauce.
Yes, she do.
She's so sweet, too.
She got that sauce.
Oh, honey.
You know you got it, baby.
I'll play that blues.
Well, that's some funky
lemonade you got goin', babe.
Is it special for me?
Did you make it today?
I'll always stop by if you
like to I'll do anything
that you want me to do.
A kiss for some of this.
A smile and it's done.
Miss, I'm your mister.
My sister's your sister.
My mother's your mother,
father's your father.
It all started
when I kissed her.
It was love at first sight.
Better when it started.
I ain't broken
hearted, but, baby.
Oh, honey.
Oh, honey, now, I
need some time alone
with the crew to do the stupid
things that we used to do.
Upon this she slammed
me with a frying pan.
Ain't it love.
I can't leave her, man.
She got sauce.
You know my baby got sauce.
Your baby ain't sweet like mine.
She ain't sweet like mine.
She got sauce.
Your baby ain't sweet like mine.
Oh, she got that sauce.
Yes, she do.
And it's so sweet, too.
Oh, baby.
Now, oh, honey.
[PLAYING HARMONICA]
You know my baby got sauce.
And of course, as a
matter, of course,
she does what she wants
to, because she's the boss.
Please don't tell my
friends about our situation.
They think I'm on some
extended vacation.
I don't get out and
see my boys anymore.
The only time I
leave my house is
to go to the store
for some of what
she, what she, what
she want me for.
What could she want this time?
I'm all hers.
She ain't even hardly mine.
Oh, baby.
And believe me, what she
do at night, I don't know.
I know that something
ain't right,
because she got me waitin'.
She comes so late, and I
try not to raise my voice,
negotiate it.
Yo, she'll win the argument.
Shouldn't have started it.
I'm broken hearted, but
you know I can't be parted.
Because my baby needs a taste.
I count my loss.
Woo!
She got that sauce.
Oh, yeah.
You know my baby got sauce.
Your baby ain't sweet like mine.
Oh, she ain't sweet like mine.
She got sauce.
Your baby ain't sweet like mine.
Yeah, she got sauce.
Oh, she do.
She's so sweet, too.
She got that sauce.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, guys.
I appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]